there's a consequence of some sort
floating around for
juju smith schuster in the aftermath of
monday night's loss to the cincinnati
bengals and that giant hit from vaughan
bell that was clearly motivated by
bell's frustration and the bengals
frustration with juju's pre-game
tick-tock dancing on the logo of the
opposing team let's hear
from coach mike tomlin tuesday meeting
with the media and talking about the
juju smith schuster dancing on the logo
controversy
i am aware of it and i do plan to talk
to juju
but we're professionals i doubt any of
those antics and things of that nature
are legitimate motivating factors
as you step into professional stadiums
but it's about respect and and so we'll
have a conversation uh but i understand
it's about the quality of play inside
the white lines and so i'm not seeking
comfort or looking for excuses uh based
on our recent performances on things
that occur in pregame or things of that
nature uh that are social media related
it's astounding to me and i love mike
tomlin as a coach chris it is astounding
to me that he would downplay the extent
to which it motivates opponents when the
opponents are saying it motivated us and
the evidence shows that hit that von
bell applied to juju's miss shuster
while fully within the rules had some
extra mustard on it by virtue of the
fact that von bell was pissed off sorry
london merry christmas by
the hit or by the dancing obviously
right obviously so i come on mike come
on mike
it's okay it's okay
to admit
that maybe you should have
seen this coming
and maybe you should have intervened
before
it led to a tone setter hit that may
have cost you a game it's okay to
acknowledge that maybe just maybe you
misread this one and should have said to
juju probably not the smartest thing for
you to do without the evidence having to
to unfold for all of us to seek well
it's i mean i hear you mike i do i do
now you know it's hard because first off
they went 11-0 with him doing this right
so it's like okay well you know the
first 11 teams saw him do this and it
wasn't a thing but it really didn't
catch fire as far as i feel like
publicly until what three four weeks ago
so it wasn't a thing where i think other
teams were looking for it you know in
week four or five or six all right the
other first i knew of it was the bills
game the sunday night football exactly
right i think i knew about it maybe a
week or two before that because of my
kids i mean my little boy he follows
juju smith schuster on tick tock so he
was the one that first kind of showed me
uh you know the little routine he did
and i didn't think really anything of it
you know it seemed harmless he's you
know in shorts and a t-shirt and doing
that you know the other aspect of this
is and we've talked about this with the
pittsburgh steelers and tomlin a lot hey
they they it's a fine line with them
they have a little bit of a renegade-ish
right attitude and player that they
attract there in pittsburgh so this is
the way they kind of play a little too
hey we're pittsburgh we're in your face
screw you we're going to be here we're
going to hit you we're going to hit you
in the mouth and that's the way we play
football that is part of it but i think
to your point and like you know for me
it's become a thing now it's become a
distraction you know i think he's
thinking about it obviously the other
teams are thinking about it cincinnati
made a lot of comments in the in the
newspaper last week in the media about
it so they were ready for it and
obviously wanted to let you know him
know where they were on the field and
buy the logo and all those type of
things so i would think they find
a compromise tommen and juju here where
hey you can dance but enough of the logo
thing like find a new place on the field
to do it to where the other team doesn't
become disrespected and we can move on
or just don't do it at all
you're right that they're renegade-ish
they play renegade at
selected games start of the fourth
quarter gets everybody fired up they are
a rough and tumble bunch they are
reality is still part of football and
they embrace that and that's the irony
of this situation assuming i'm using the
word correctly and i still never know
whether i am that they had the
physicality brought to
them you're right back to where we
started with unforced errors this entire
thing was an unforced error and the
mistake for mike tomlin and i know that
he tries to craft the right relationship
with his players to get the most out of
them while letting them be themselves
and other coaches who have to deal with
his players when they leave
marvel
at what tomlin is able to do with some
of these guys because when they get them
in their locker room they're like how in
the hell am i going to get through to
this guy how did mike tomlin do it
tomlin knows how to do it but in this
one there was a blind spot there was
there was an underestimation of the
impact of that dance routine on a
teammate and they probably also thought
who gives a crap if the bengals are
upset they're the banks i agreed i think
they thought okay we've lost two
it's the bengals this is going to kind
of show that we're not backing down from
anybody he was trying to probably keep
the attitude of his team yeah positive
and that you know renegade tough
blitzburg type attitude that they play
with you know there but yeah it's
backfired and i'll tell you like what
did it for me too i'll tell you is juju
smith schuster
i i i'm he fumbled and he was on the
sideline and he was talking about it i'm
almost positive so if he's sitting there
talking about it on the sideline that to
me is when you know like it's gone too
far you're it's the first quarter of a
football game and you're talking about
your dance on the logo like i think
that's a distraction so let's move on
and not do it anymore
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports